Wir wollen jetzt blicken auf die Serie A, La Liga, die Premier League und die Ligue 1. Das tun wir mit Michael Postel, Alex Treuker, Christian Bernhardt und Uli Hebel. Mein Name ist Max Jacob Ost und das hier ist die Rasenfunk Ligatour. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk. Ich verstehe nicht, wie meine Gäste hier sitzen können, wie Denkmäler. Ich dachte schon, alle eures Dreams seien eingefroren. Aber gut, so ist es eben. Bin ich eben der Einzige, der sich über dieses Intro freut. Schön, dass ihr alle drei da seid. Uli Hebel wird noch später dazu kommen. Und wir machen gar nicht lange rum. Wir starten direkt rein in die Sendung. Alex, lass uns mal mit La Liga beginnen. Wir wollen nach Spanien blicken und erwerfen große Ereignisse, ihren Schatten, keine Ahnung, was das auf Spanisch heißt, voraus.
Und hat wahrscheinlich Christian in Italien auch Wellen geschlagen?
Ja, klar. Ich habe auch extra nochmal nachgeschaut, wie Alex ja auch gesagt hat. Er war ja zweimal davor schon bei Juwe. Und ich habe mir extra noch ein paar Interviews von ihm damals rausgesucht. Und da ist das auch schon durchgeklungen. Also das ist halt das, was ihn schon lange begleitet. Ich habe das Interview noch aus 2021 gefunden, in seinem zweiten Juwe-Aufenthalt. Und da hat er auch schon gemeint, der Druck, eben dieses in der Öffentlichkeit stehen, das beschäftigt ihn sehr. Also ich glaube, da reden wir jetzt nicht über was, was erst vor einem halben Jahr oder einem Jahr bei ihm aufgetreten ist, sondern das hat ihn wirklich schon sehr lange begleitet. Und dementsprechend, glaube ich, ist es für ihn wirklich, so wie Alex ja gesagt hat, er hatte wirklich das Gefühl, er muss Spanien fluchtartig verlassen. Und es ist ihm wirklich zu wünschen, dass er in Italien jetzt wieder quasi eine gute Zeit findet. Denn seine Zeit in Turin, die war wirklich sehr positiv. Also er ist zwar ein Spanier, klar ist er kein Italiener, aber er hat sich auch oft gesagt, Turin ist für ihn auch eine zweite Heimat geworden. Seine Frau, von der er sich mittlerweile getrennt hat, ist ja auch Italienerin. Also er hat da wirklich einen sehr engen Bezug. Und deswegen war das jetzt zwar für ihn eine Flucht, aber ich glaube, er ist irgendwo hingekommen, wo er, glaube ich schon, ja, wo er schon in den Jahren davor halt sehr viele positiven Erfahrungen, sei ich jetzt auch mal Lebenserfahrungen gemacht hat. Klar, es ist in Mailand nicht Turin, aber es ist nicht weit entfernt. Dementsprechend ist ihm, glaube ich, wirklich zu wünschen, dass er wieder so ein bisschen persönliche Ruhe findet, eben auch mit den Kindern eben. Er hat ja vier Kinder. Das Thema hattet ihr letztes Mal ja auch schon. Da ist er ja auch sehr sensibel, was logischerweise die Öffentlichkeit betrifft rund um seine Kinder. Ja, also Morata ist schon sehr spezieller, sehr sensibler, aber das meine ich jetzt im Positiven. Ich bin Fußballprofi und da bin ich voll bei Alex. Ich glaube, es ist auch wichtig, dass Spieler dieser Größe, dieser Karatur dann so ein Thema auch mal öffentlich ansprechen, weil da doch vielleicht dann auch öffentliche Diskussionen in den Gang gehen.
Genau, man muss ein bisschen aufpassen, dann die Begriffe nicht durcheinander zu werfen. depression ist eine Krankheit und niemand bekommt wegen öffentlichen Drucks eine Krankheit. Da gibt es sehr interessante Aussagen auch von der teresa Encke, der Robert-Encke-Stiftung, dazu von teresa Encke, aber es spielt eben definitiv mit eine Rolle. Und wenn man eben selbst von etwas betroffen ist, muss man eben wissen, depressionen sind sehr gut behandelbar. Man muss Menschen, die davon betroffen sind, helfen, den Schritt zu schaffen, in diese Behandlung rein, weil dieser Schritt kann riesig, kann monumental aussehen und das sollte jeder von uns tun. Und dementsprechend ist es eben auch wichtig, dass wir hier an dieser Stelle so etwas thematisieren und da ist es eben auch sehr förderlich, wenn ein sehr prominenter Spieler da sehr offen drüber spricht. Das sind ja wirklich sehr eindrucksvolle Zitate von Alvaro Morata. Tja, irgendwie werden wir jetzt wahrscheinlich trotzdem wieder aufs Sportliche zurückkommen. Es ist ja doch noch der Fokus dieser Sendung. Christian, wenn du eh gerade dein Mikrofon noch offen hast, über welche zwei Spieler würdest du denn gerne noch sprechen?
Ja, fangen wir mit dem MVP an. Das schließt so ein bisschen an Alex an. In Italien gibt es auch einen Herren, der munter drauf losknippst diese Saison. Das ist Matteo Retegi, Atalanta-Stürmer und Nationalstürmer. Hat jetzt siebenmal getroffen in den ersten sieben Ligaspielen, zuletzt vor der Länderspielpause in Hetrick, ein Dreierpack. Dazu noch eine Vorlage. Also ist wirklich in einer beneidenswerten Verfassung. Hat jetzt auch in der Länderspielpause in beiden Spielen für Italien getroffen. Und hätte auch noch mehr Buden machen können. Hat auch ein bisschen was liegen lassen. Aber Retegi hat wirklich den Sprung jetzt geschafft. Der ist ja im Sommer aus Genoa nach zu Atalanta gewechselt. Nachdem sich Skamaka, der eigentliche A-Stürmer von Atalanta und ja auch ein bisschen eigentliche A-Stürmer der Nationalmannschaft das Kreuzband gerissen hatte, hat Atalanta– schwupps-di-wupps– zwei Tage später Retegi geholt für 22 Millionen. Und das besondere daran ist, dass der wirklich null Anlaufzeit gebracht hat. Wie gesagt, sieben Tore, sieben Spiele. Also der ist dahin gekommen zu Gasperini, war sofort mit drin. Und wenn wir uns anschauen, was Gasperini in den letzten Jahren aus Offensivspielern rausgeholt hat, wenn wir schauen, was er aus Lukmen gemacht hat, wenn wir schauen, wie er es aus Skamaka gemacht hat, wenn wir schauen, was er aus Deketelare gemacht hat nach dem einen ersten so schwierigen Jahr bei Milan, dann zeigt das eben, dass Gasperini gerade auf die Offensivspieler einen großen Impact haben kann. Und wenn dann ein Spieler schon sofort funktioniert, dann können wir davon ausgehen, dass das in den nächsten Monaten auch nicht unbedingt schlechter wird, weil er wirklich einfach perfekt in dieses System reinpasst. Mittlerweile auch sehr gut in das Nationalmannschaftssystem. Das sind nicht nur Tore, er funktioniert auch gut als Wandspieler, war immer schon einer, der sehr fleißig war, ist ja gebürtiger Argentinier, bringt auch wirklich diesen argentinischen Piss gegen den Ball mit. Und darauf konntest du dich eh schon immer verlassen. Wenn du jetzt auch noch so verlässlich knippst, dann ist das sehr beeindruckend. Und letzter Satz dazu, mich erinnert es sehr an Luqman, denn Luqman kam auch zu Atalanta und hat sofort funktioniert. Das war wirklich, er hat keine Einlaufzeit bei Gasperini gebraucht. Das war vor zwei Jahren, wenn wir gesehen haben, wohin der Weg von Luqman geführt hat, was er letzte Saison auch in der Europa League angestellt, was er jetzt auch weiter in der Champions League macht. Dann ist da, glaube ich, wirklich bei Retegi noch weiterhin Potenzial da.
Und dann hast du noch jemanden, der so ein bisschen unterm Radar läuft, aber auch…
Genau. Ja, er läuft unterm Radar im Kontext. Ich wollte kurz auf Napoli schauen. Napoli ist der Tabellenführer und der Konter. Lukaku im letzten Spiel vor der Pause, zwei Tore gemacht, eins vorbereitet. Quaratzkelia funktioniert, neres funktioniert von der Bank. McDominick hat jetzt sein erstes Tor erzielt. Also, es gibt genügend geschichten bei Napoli, wo wieder viele Offensiven im Fokus stehen, so wie im Meisterjahr Osemen und Quaratzkelia. Aber der eine Mann, der wieder dahin gekommen ist, wo er auch im Meisterjahr war, ist Lobotka. Und deswegen funktioniert Napoli auch so langsam wieder, wie das Napoli, was viele von uns noch vor eineinhalb Jahren gekannt haben. Am letzten Spieltag, jetzt, war echt eine wunderschöne geschichte vor der Länderspielpause. Napoli gewinnt 3-1 gegen Como. Der Trainer von Como, wie ihr wisst, Fabregas, also einer, dem ich zugestehen würde, der ein bisschen gespür hat für diese Position, meinte nach dem Spiel, Zitat, Mama mia, Lobotka, was für ein Spieler. Gebt ihm mir bitte, wie der das Spiel liest, wie er das Spiel versteht, wie er die Bälle gewinnt. Um die ganze Mannschaft dreht sich um ihn. Das war direkt nach dem Spiel bei der Zone, unten am Spielfeldrand. Auf der pressekonferenz hat er noch mal zwei Minuten über Lobotka geredet, hat gemeint, ich will elf Lobotkas in meiner Mannschaft. Also ich will eine Mannschaft, die aus elf Lobotkas besteht. Daraus würde ich meinen Fußball kreieren. Xavi hat letzte Saison, als Napoli gegen Barca gespielt hat, öffentlich über ihn gesprochen. Ist auch in Italien verbrieft, dass Barcelona im Sommer wieder angeklopft hat bei Lobotka. Da hat sich Conte aber vehement gewehrt. Also was ich damit sagen will, er ist der klassische Spieler, über den vielleicht öffentlich nicht immer so viel geredet wird, aber der gerade für diese Art und Weise, wie Napoli Fußball spielt, unfassbar wichtig ist. Und Conte weiß das auch. Und es gab eine Szene, er hat ihn jetzt gegen Como, er hat ihn in der 89. ausgewechselt, wissend, dass es Standing-O-Mations geben würde. Und als er rauskam, hat er ihn umarmt und geküsst. Also quasi wirklich vor aller Augen. Und wer Conte kennt, weiß, das ist nicht einer, der Spieler gerne, sag ich mal, in der Öffentlichkeit so quasi herausbickt und über die anderen stellt. Aber da hat er eben gemerkt, hat sie ihn auch übermahnt, hat er danach selber erzählt, er wollte einfach Lobotka diese Bühne geben. Und ich habe mich auch deshalb für Lobotka entschieden, weil er sich jetzt in der Nationalmannschaft verletzt hat. Fällt jetzt wohl die nächsten zwei Wochen aus, verpasst mindestens zwei Spiele, vielleicht auch das Milan-Spiel, den ersten großen Kacher jetzt, Ende des Monats. Und deswegen wird es spannend sein, wie Napoli seinen Ausfall jetzt erstmal verkraftet. Vielleicht sieht man nochmal mehr, wie viel er wert ist. Aber Gilmour wird jetzt reinrutschen, der bekommt seine Chance und deswegen Lobotka als ein Spieler, der vielleicht nicht immer im Fokus steht.
Steht hiermit offiziell auf einer Stufe mit Dante, denn auch da hat ein Trainer mal gesagt, ich hätte gerne Elf dantes. 1000 dantes, oder?
50.000?
Ja, vielleicht waren sogar mehr. Das wäre ein Fußballspiel, das würde ich auch gerne sehen. Elf dantes gegen Elf Lobotkas. Dann schauen wir mal, was dabei rauskommt. Aber das ist jetzt ein ganz anderes Thema. Dann lasst uns nochmal auf die Premier League blicken, Uli, zwei Spieler, die du gerne hier aufs podest heben würdest.
Also mein MVP ist wirklich ein echter solcher. Ich nehme Bria im Bümo von Brentford. Die sind ordentlich gestartet mit dem vergleichsweise leichten Programm. Zwar aber zehn Punkte aus sieben Spielen. Das ist sehr gut. Im Bümo hat er gleiche Zahlen wie Retegi. Sechs Tore in sieben Spielen. Das ist deshalb so wichtig, weil er so extrem gefehlt hat und die fast noch Richtung Abstieg geguckt hätten. Vergangenen Saison, als er nicht mit dabei war. Vor allen Dingen, weil Ivan Toni kurz vor Ende der Transferperiode nach Saudi-Arabien gewechselt ist. Der immer so als derjenige galt, ohne dem nichts geht. Wir haben bei Click & Rush auch schon gesagt, dass das eher ein Bümo ist und nicht so sehr Toni. Der macht jetzt genau da weiter, wo er eigentlich aufgehört hat, bevor er sich letzte Saison schwer verletzt hat. Er ist ein super Abschlussspieler, sehr zielgerichtet, ist ständig in die Tiefe unterwegs, arbeitet nach hinten. Er ist eigentlich so was wie der offensive Fixpunkt und so schwierig zu verteidigen, weil er auch so kompakt ist als Spieler und sehr schnell, sehr direkt, aber auch ein gutes Trickrepertoire hat, sodass der, glaube ich, wirklich im wahrsten Sinne des wortes wertvolles der Spieler genannt werden muss für Brentford.
Aber ist das jetzt eine jüngere Entwicklung, weil er spielt da jetzt schon viele Jahre bei Brentford, kam von Thora?
Die Wichtigkeit ja, die Effizienz, würde ich auch sagen, ist deutlich besser geworden. Aber alles in allem war der schon, also der Kern bei Brentford ist sowieso seit Jahren der gleiche. Das kann man auch als Kritikpunkt sehen, aber das ist im Grunde genommen der selbe Kern, der aufgestiegen ist und die Premier League seither bestreitet. Der war nicht immer ganz gesund. Ich würde auch immer noch ein Fragezeichen dahinter setzen, ob das über 38 Spiele so gehen kann in dieser Saison. Aber der entwickelt sich einfach steht. Der hatte, wie klassisch Brentford-Spieler das haben, Löcher, als sie ihn geholt haben im Spiel. Hatte aber brutale Stärken. Damals waren wir kurz vor Corona noch im alten Brentford-Stadion. Da haben wir nur beim Aufwärmen zugeguckt und haben gesagt, das ist ja Wahnsinn, was der für einen Abschluss hat. Da ist jeder einzelne Ball scharf drin. Das kommt jetzt langsam aber sicher auch in der Premier League an. deswegen würde ich sagen, das sind relativ stete Entwicklungen. Es ist aber trotzdem wahrscheinlich immer noch kein Spieler, der jetzt allerorts auf den Schirmen wäre.
Wenn man sich die letzten Premier League-Saisons anguckt, hat er ja auch vier Tore, neun Tore, neun Tore. Jetzt hat er schon sechs, nach sieben Spielen. Also auf einem hervorragenden Weg, das mal zu übertreffen und dann im Brandenlicht zu stehen. Und dann gibt es ja auch immer die Spieler, die so ein bisschen untergehen, die Lobotkas, wie ich so gerne sage, dieser Welt. Wen gibt es denn da in der Premier League, Uli?
Ich habe jetzt einfach mal stellvertretend Carlos Baleba rausgesucht von Brighton, den wahrscheinlich jetzt noch nicht die Allermeisten kennen werden, der 18 Monate in Lille gespielt hat, davor aus Cameroon kam, da war er noch viel unbekannter, dann nach Brighton gegangen ist. Und dann hat im Januar der Zerbi über ihn gesagt, ah, da fehlt es aber noch weit, bis der Premier League-Spieler sein kann. Zwei Wochen später ist er Stammspieler. Und nochmal fast-forward, jetzt Runde neun Monate später sieht er aus wie einer, der im zentralen Defensiven Mittelfeld alles können könnte, ist physisch, kann 6er, könnte 8er, ist ein unglaublicher Ball-Carrier, also es kann sehr, sehr vertikal das Spiel ankurbeln, ist clever im Antizipieren, super geschickter Spieler einfach und hat eine Laufleistung, die habe ich so noch nicht gesehen, ist auch glaube ich ganz wichtig bei diesem Bielsa-artigen Hürzeler-Fußball in Brighton im Moment und glaube einer, von dem wir sehr, sehr viel hören werden. Also würde mich nicht wundern, wenn das der nächste ist, den dann alle irgendwann mal wollen.
Carlos Baleba, hier habt ihr den Namen zuerst gehört. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ja ihr vier, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat große Freude gemacht mit euch mal wieder heute über ein breites Thebenspektrum über europäischen Fußball bei den Männern zu sprechen. Ich danke sehr herzlich. Michi Postel, danke, dass sie hier warst.
Danke auch.
Herzlichen Dank an Alex Treuker, auch noch gemutet.
Sehr gerne, es ist mir immer wieder eine Freude.
Schön, dass du hier warst. Danke, Christian. Vielen Dank auch. Danke dir.
Viel Spaß gemacht.
Und herzlichen Dank an Uli Hebel. Schön, dass du trotz engem Terminplan immer noch schaffst, hier wieder rein zu sneaken in die Ligatur. Danke dir.
Ach ja, ich komme halt immer so zehn Minuten später, aber dann ist alles erledigt. Danke auch.
Ich lasse jetzt alle Gags, die hier liegen und vielleicht mit Kollegen von uns allen zu tun haben, liegen und sage danke euch und ich danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, für eure Aufmerksamkeit und für euren Support, denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist werbepayable und sponsorenfrei. alles, was wir hier machen, ist von euch finanziert, damit auch die Gästehonorare, die wir zahlen. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei einfachfrida, bei faröing, bei domsen, bei ante martin und bei torben l. Sie alle sind Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter. Sie sind auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclubgegangenundhaben uns unterstützt. Ihr könnt auch auf rasenfunk.de gehen und einfach auf unterstützen klicken. Viele Wege führen zum Rasenfunk-Support, also keine Ausreden. Auch kleine Beträge helfen. Herzlichen Dank an alle, die es getan haben. Und danke, wenn ihr diese Folge weiter empfiehlt, wenn ihr uns Feedback dalasst und wenn ihr auch die anderen Rasenfunk-Feeds abonniert. Es gibt 5 einfach nach Rasenfunk in der Podcast-App. eures Vertrauen zu. In diesem Sinne, bleibt gesund, bis bald, macht's gut. Ciao! Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!